Chicago in The Lightfoot era has been a
war zone none of that is particularly
surprising to people who pay attention
to the news what is surprising what is
delightfully surprising is that Chicago
residents are finally doing something
about it Lori Lightfoot lost her
re-election bid for Chicago mayor
she didn't even make the top two which
means that Paul vallis and Brandon
Johnson will head to the April 4th
runoff in the race Lori Lightfoot will
ride off into the sunset all of this
should give at least some hope to
dejected conservatives who think that
there is no hope for the country if even
Screwed Up Chicago can muster the
political vision and will to throw a bum
out what's stopping the rest of us from
doing the same thing at the national
level